I'm right on the museum island and Bella
here you'll find five museums and I want
to show you three of them in 360 degrees
the item at suny gallery the itis Museum
and the neues museum on my tour you can
decide what you want to see just look
around
put on your VR glasses move your
smartphone out focus on your PC on the
area and direction that you are
interested in
[Music]
take a look at the architecture of the
attend attend a gallery the design of
the building is based on a sketch by
King Frederick William the fourth of
Prussia
the museum was founded after banker and
consul who died in 1861 donated a
collection of artworks to the Prussian
state this gift included works by Caspar
David Friedrich and Carol Shanklin
[Music]
the i-10 at Sanaa gallery displays
paintings and sculptures representative
of the major art movements of the 19th
century
[Music]
among them you'll find the
Impressionists on the second floor
particularly well-known is the winter
gone by a Dewani
[Music]
the third floor is dedicated to
exhibiting art from the romantic and
realist movements
[Music]
and now let's go to the next Museum on
the left side of the item on our gallery
you'll find the neues museum with its
neoclassical architecture
it has prehistoric and early historic
collections and shows ancient Egyptian
artifacts so let's go inside and have a
look
[Music]
9,000 objects are displayed at the noise
Museum among them statues and sacrifices
[Music]
there are many highlights including the
bust of Nefertiti which unfortunately
cannot be filmed as well as this ancient
skeleton the boy of Santa in the Buccos
hole over there in front of the windows
is worth a look the antique bronze
statue originally served as a valley
stand
offering guests a tray filled with
drinks and snacks
[Music]
antiquity also plays an important role
in the next museum behind me you see the
itís museum the foundation building of
the first royal and nowadays state-run
museums of berlin and as you can see it
has a prominent position next to the
berlin cathedral and the city castle
that's being reconstructed at the moment
and when you look at the architecture of
the old museum you might think of the
ancient Greece and that's what expects
you inside
[Music]
the Rotunda puts you in the mood for
ancient Greek Etruscan and Roman
exhibits making it a great place to
start the ground floor gives insight
into the development of ancient Greek ad
[Music]
on the upper floor you will find
exhibits focusing on Etruscans and
Romans well known here is the green
Caesar bust and the depiction of
Cleopatra next to it both of them were
also probably the most famous lovers of
antiquity on the museum island other
than the I 10 attend a gallery the
artists Museum and neues Museum you'll
find the Pergamon and border museums
these are also well worth a visit but
visiting all exhibition houses in one
day would be a bit too much
[Music]